with Godzilla minus one and Apple's
Monarch Atomic blasting its way through
my heart it's been one hell of a good
year for Godzilla fans and a reminder
just how far we've
come I don't know what this is but it's
kind OFA Monarch Legacy of the Monsters
has been a bit of a big surprise for me
adding in this really cool element of
time dilation big monster battles and a
surprisingly emotional final episode
there's no doubt that the finale is the
best of the season and in this video
we'll be going over all its Mysteries
how time works here and what that ending
could mean for season 2 so get in your
capsules and smash that like And
subscribe button because here we go the
final episode begins in axis Mundi the
name Dr kikura gave to the realm in
between our world Earth and the world of
the Titans Hollow Earth we saw Hollow
Earth in 2021s Godzilla versus Kong but
this place is a blend between the two
think of it like like a pit stop between
two places through millions of years
this place has sucked in elements from
both worlds creating a patchwork of Flor
and fauna that have developed into its
own ecosystem at the end of episode 8
Kate Randa a descendant of Dr Bill Randa
who we saw at the beginning of episode 1
and who died in 1973 while on Skull
Island was sucked into a portal at an
abandoned nuclear reactor in Kazakhstan
these portals connect our world to axis
Mundi and then to the hollow Earth but a
access to them is only possible when the
energy around them has been stabilized
in episode 9 General Pucket explains the
presence of a Titan can do this allowing
humans to travel through them safely but
harnessing a Titan is a completely
different matter luckily Dr Suzuki
developed what's known as a gamma
emitter which sends out blasts of gamma
rays which attract Titans to it allowing
Monarch crew members to trail behind the
Titans in these metal capsules into the
worlds Beyond both Kate and Koo however
didn't get here in the safety of one of
these capsules they made it without any
protection whatsoever proving that
travel between Realms is possible
without the need for elaborate ships
capsules or vehicles but what KO doesn't
know is that Kate is her granddaughter
from 56 years in the future that's
because time works differently in axis
Mundi than it does up top now the show
plays fast and loose with how much time
passes in our world for every day that
passes in axis Mundi so I created this
chart to give us a better idea of how
things played out KO left our world in
1959 and when Kate arrived in axis Mundi
it was 2015 KO says she spent roughly 57
days alone here thus we can conclude
that for KO one day in axis Mundi equals
about one year in our world now let's
take a look at Lee Shaw who arrived in
axis Mundi in 1962 and came back to
Earth in 1982 he says he was in axis for
about a week thus for Lee one day in
axis was about 3 years on Earth finally
there's Kate and may they arrived in
axis in 2015 and reemerge up top in 2017
now we don't have an official number but
I estimate that they were in axis Mundi
for about 8 hours if my math is correct
one day in axis Mundy would be 6 years
up top for Kate and may but since they
were only here for 8 hours it works out
to 2 years now you'll see that there's a
discrepancy there isn't a consistent one
day equals 1 year kind of thing going on
here this could be because time
continually changes here it warps and
shifts and honestly this is probably the
easiest answer because it allows the
writer Some Lee way see what I did there
in shaping their story speaking of Lee
we get this emotional reunion between
him and KO although he's 56 years older
than the last time these two saw each
other he and KO were once in love that
was before she started a life with Bill
Randa in episode 6 Lee risked losing all
of Monarch's funding just so that he
could be with KO and from that moment on
KO knew Lee would always put her before
anything else thus things kind of come
full circle when he'll later sacrifice
himself so that she can live but more on
that and whether he's actually dead in a
bit with the arrival of Lee we get some
of the most emotional scenes in the
entire season and holy imagine
finding out all at once that your
husband died your son is all grown up
and this grown ass woman is your
granddaughter it's more dramatic than an
episode of Mory we get to see Ko's
encamp where she spent the last several
weeks spending most of her time
reconfiguring the gamma emitter that was
left behind when Lee arrived in 1962 we
can calculate that she found this
emitter roughly 10 days or more after
arriving at axis Mundi unfortunately
there's not a lot of time for all of
them to catch up as Lee has an idea to
get them back to Earth Lee fills Koo in
on some of the things she's missed but
don't worry she'll be back just in time
for covid Lee's hairbrain scheme
involves using the capsule from 1962 to
make make their way back to present day
luckily down here it's only been a few
weeks since the capsule was left behind
and thus still has enough juice to power
up this allows them to turn on the gamma
emitter to lure a Titan from the hollow
Earth which theoretically should allow
them to travel back but KO says she is
staying behind the world she would go
back to isn't hers her husband is dead
her son grew up without knowing her and
she doesn't want to risk ruining his
life again but it's Kate who convinces
her to come they need her and as she
agrees and the gang is ready to go we
get the appearance of a Titan known as
the loton dragon named after the naval
ship Bill Randa served on that became
the nesting ground for this creature in
the Philippines as Bill Randa recalls it
killed all his crew members and he was
the only one to survive all these Titans
appear to be a threat to humanity
especially Godzilla who after gday
became a massive threat with places like
Tokyo constructing makeshift Titan
bunkers and evacuation routes but Lee
believes Godzilla isn't a threat threat
that he is actually a protector and
we'll see this come into play when
Godzilla fights off the lot and dragon
as they make their escape this is a
departure from Godzilla minus one where
Godzilla is definitely the bad guy
during one of the Dragons attacks a
cable connecting the emitter to its
power source is disconnected and thus
Lee Ventures out into the chaos to put
it back together as the capsule is
sucked into the portal he knows that
there's too much weight and then he must
sacrifice himself if the others are to
live so he lets go his Last Words being
thank you and I love the juxtoposition
of Kazakhstan 1959 and here where we can
see the two of them holding on to each
other this time it's Lee who lets go but
is he gone for good considering KO
survived down here it's entirely
possible first he didn't necessarily
fall from a huge height so there's that
he'd then have to survive the energy
blast which is also not impossible but
then there's the question of what does
he do from here if you look really
closely the emitter which KO used to
send signals top side rips off just
before taking off we'll also see the
capsule arrive in the year 2017 with no
emitter attached to it theoretically
it's still down there with Lee all he
would need is a power source and
considering this place is filled with
weird upside down lightning blasts maybe
he can make something work we also know
the laws of physics act differently down
in axis money so there's a lot of
potential for finding ways to have him
come back but what if Lee made his way
through that portal anyway it's totally
possible that if he let go he'd get
sucked up to considering his weight is
far less than this giant capsule which
got sucked up this then raises the
question where did he go or when did he
go or did he get to the hollow Earth
itself it hasn't really been explained
in the show how to get to the hollow
Earth we've only made it halfway there
to axis Mundy now when may Kate and KO
arrive in their present day which they
find out is 2 years later in the year
2017 members of Apex cybernetics are
already waiting for them including
canaro and Hiroshi like Kate canaro has
has had a very tumultuous relationship
with his father who kept a secret second
family in America and fled off to Alaska
abandoning them in the final episode we
do get some answers as to his motivation
he wanted to draw out a Titan to prove
these networks of gateways leading to
the worlds of the Titans exist he wanted
to prove that his mother and father were
right if he can do this perhaps he can
prevent another gday and if that meant
abandoning his family to save the world
it was a sacrifice he was willing to
make Hiroshi believes that humanity and
the Titans can coexist which makes it
all the more interesting that he and
canaro end up allying themselves with
Apex cybernetics this is the company
that in Godzilla versus Kong aims to
control Titans and imprison them
basically making them Humanity slaves
that hardly sounds like a peaceful
coexistence now the events of Godzilla
versus Kong in which Apex uses neuralink
technology to control a Mecca Godzilla
to kill the real Godzilla take place 7
years after after Kate and may arrive
topside so there's a lot of stuff that
can happen in between this time period
that the Monarch writers can play with
it was hiroshi's math that led Apex to
know where Kate May and Koo would emerge
and check out this spherical device that
almost looks as though it's either
stabilizing or controlling some beam
into the portal could it be some sort of
new version of the gamma emitter or
something else entirely perhaps a way to
control these portals in Godzilla versus
Kong we know that there's eventually
technology that allows humans to travel
to and from the hollow Earth so maybe
this is a precursor to that and after 58
years KO is reunited with her son
Hiroshi who is technically older than
her now and also gets to meet her second
grandchild canaro but the presence of
Brenda Hollander the executive of
Applied experimental Technologies is of
serious concern to may may used to work
for Brenda and expose that a was
conducting cruel scientific experiments
on animals at the end of episode 7 we
learned that Brenda made some sort of
deal with Apex cybernetics thus bringing
her into the fold with Hoshi and canaro
who are now working for them an alarm
siren goes off as May asks Brenda what
the hell is going on to which she
replies only everything I ever promised
you Brenda told me that together they
would change the world so this is likely
what's happening as we pull out of the
hanger we see that we're at apex's
research station on Skull Island the
home of Kong and Brenda doesn't seem too
concerned that this giant Beast is only
a few hundred meters away perhaps Apex
has some sort of way to deal with him I
also found it odd that there's this
random red helicopter here it seems like
a very distinct Choice it's important to
note that Monarch also has two outposts
on Skull Island Outpost 33 and 236 these
were put in place to watch Kong and
ensure the protection of the island so
it looks like season 2 is going to have
a big showdown between Apex and Monarch
with Skull Island as the potential
Battleground but now I turn it over to
you what did you think of Monarch season
1 I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much